gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france en 24 estamos de regreso para
actualizar las principales noticias en
materia económica junto a daniela
blandón por supuesto muy buenas noches
danny vamos a comenzar hablando de bueno
una mala noticia para la región de
américa latina cayó lo que es la
inversión directa extranjera quise decir
perdón sin santiago en 2020 como
consecuencia de la pandemia muy buenas
noches esta región fue la región en
desarrollo en la que más cayó esta
inversión extranjera directa en el
primer año de pandemia según el estudio
anual que hacen naciones unidas- de 160
mil millones de dólares en 2019 la cifra
bajó a 88 mil millones en 2020 veamos el
descenso en latinoamérica fue incluso
mayor al 35 por ciento del promedio
mundial por países los más afectados
fueron perú y brasil con descensos del
87 y el 62 por ciento respectivamente
y américo le fue relativamente bien pues
la recepción de inversiones apenas bajó
un 15% de hecho este país se consolidó
como uno de los 10
un 2 y el primero en latinoamérica que
más inversión extranjera directa recibió
afortunados los mexicanos bueno vamos
ahora a cubano porque a partir de hoy
lunes ya no se pueden depositar lo que
son dólares en efectivo verdad
santiago pues a los bancos cubanos se
les prohibió aceptar depósitos en
dólares en una polémica medida que en
adelante va a dificultar el uso de esta
moneda y que el gobierno justificó en el
embargo de eeuu la decisión entró en
vigencia este lunes pero fue anunciada
al 10 de junio desde ese momento se
vieron largas filas en los bancos de
personas queriendo consignar sus ahorros
en dólares desde el día del anuncio de
hecho el precio del dólar frente a la
moneda local que es el peso cubano se ha
depreciado el valor oficial del dólar es
de 24 pesos pero en el mercado ilegal se
llegó a disparar a 70 y ahora se ha
estabilizado en alrededor de 50 pesos de
cuba a eeuu tenía para hablar de un
proyecto piloto referencia el ingreso
básico no que se está poniendo en marcha
si santiago mitre se trata de un
programa de ingreso básico universal
financia
por el sector privado en este caso el
mismo que organismos como la cepal han
recomendado a los gobiernos a aplicar en
américa latina' para salir de la crisis
y que también se está probando en otros
estados como california o virginia el
condado de buster ubicado al norte de
nueva york comenzó a entregar 500
dólares mensuales por espacio de un año
a 100 de sus residentes que ganen menos
de 46 mil 900 dólares al año aunque se
inscribieron más de 4200 santiago pues
no necesariamente tienen que ser que
sean desempleados los destinatarios
pueden usar los recursos como deseen
pero si deben reportar en que lo hacen
cuál es el objetivo de esto su programa
santiago que investigadores analicen en
qué se gasta la plata esta gente y ver
qué repercusiones tiene sobre la
economía y la calidad de vida los
críticos de esta clase de iniciativas
temen por que no sean muy efectivas o
que no lleguen a quienes de verdad lo
necesitan
continuamos ahora en el medio oriente no
vamos a la franja de gaza donde los
agricultores no la están pasando nada
bien no están teniendo pérdidas millón
arias verdad claro pues cuando en mayo
estalló el más reciente episodio en la
guerra entre israel y el grupo hamas que
duró 11 días desde tel aviv ordenaron el
cierre del cruce de kerem shalom por ahí
pasan diariamente miles de productos
desde gaza hacia israel y los
territorios palestinos pero a pesar de
que hubo un social fuego
este paso comercial siguió cerrado por
40 días y este lunes se abrió pero con
limitaciones la multinacional pepsi por
ejemplo se vio obligada a detener sus
operaciones en casa mientras que hamás
que controla la zona dice que se han
generado pérdidas diarias por 300.000
dólares escuchemos todas las hortalizas
de la franja de gaza se distribuyen en
el mercado local y la oferta se ha
vuelto muy grande lo que ha provocado
una gran caída de los precios eso está
generando enormes pérdidas para los
agricultores y trabajadores del sector
agrícola
danny avanzamos ahora con los
indicadores de la jornada que nos dicen
claro que si wall street' del cerro con
ganancias en un intento por recuperar
todo lo perdido la semana pasada en su
peor momento desde octubre las bolsas
europeas
son alentadas por el banco central que
dijo que hay un mensaje optimista sobre
la economía ante el parlamento y américa
latina cerró con leves variaciones en
sao paulo el precio del dólar rompió
récord finalizamos como siempre con la
esperada cifra del día cuales 180 y 1.5
millones de dólares por este valor el
banco de desarrollo de américa latina o
la caf realizó su primera colocación de
bonos dirigidos a financiar programas de
nutrición en américa latina' gracias por
estar completísima crónicas de aquí la
información económica en france 24 o
sigan con nosotros
[Música]